mon nom est kuba je m'occupe surtout de ma mère
ce qui était père comme il était juste
comme toi mère forte et si
belle j'utilise la magie pour raconter des histoires si
tu dois cligner des yeux
fais-le maintenant Oh batailles épiques guerriers
homards mais je n'avais aucune idée que mes histoires
étaient  en fait vrai nous
te cherchons depuis si longtemps tu dois trouver
l'armure de ton père c'est ta seule chance
qui es tu
ta famille est très puissante ta mère a
utilisé ma magie pour te sauver et m'apporter une
vie je suis là pour te protéger  Kubo et
cela signifie que vous devez faire ce que je dis
ne plaisante pas avec le singe avez-vous déjà vu
cette robe bien sûr c'est un
miracle j'ai trouvé le fils de mon
maître votre quête est maintenant ma quête - nous
ne savons pas  rien à propos de toi tirant une
flèche c'est à peine ce que j'appelle impressionnant
littéralement la première fois que j'ai fait
ta magie devient plus forte tu
dois apprendre à contrôler
ne touchez à rien il l'a fait
j'ai compris cela je n'ai pas cette réclamation votre
le droit d'aînesse dans une maison coopérative donne à cette
histoire une fin heureuse  ng
ouais as-tu besoin d'un peu d'aide
non non non oui